you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game
let's try d4
and see what Alex double h throws at us
a Benko of an Oni all right let's go for
Knight f3
we're gonna go h3 Bishop f4 III I'm not
going to put my pawn on e4
let's stop b5
I'm going to be careful about allowing
this night to move
you know why I hesitated so much saying
move but yeah I don't want this bishop
to see the world so easily so that's why
I'm playing Knight d2 instead of a a
normal issue of like Bishop e2 and my
knight is on his way to c4 as well
definitely backing up it's a super
valuable piece restricting the Queen we
might say uh-huh
they are insisting on a dark square
bishop exchange makes sense well I don't
want to go on castled so I guess we're
gonna take I see no reason to not jump
right in right now and I guess we can
strike at the night so the dark square
bishop have been exchanged their king is
vulnerable go look for this kind of
stuff into f6
probably castle
clean how to do that before night here
hmm okay well let's let's maybe look to
clamp down on b6 yeah this might be a
pretty good idea let's do this cuz I
don't know I think I want another night
here to put pressure on that pond is
there something better they're trying to
go for more exchanges
let's try this just pivoting on the v6
square
I don't know if I want to jump in right
now can I improve my bishop my queen hmm
my queen has to watch over this pawn I
think I want to avoid I want to meet
Knight there with Knight b6 maybe
it's a bit tricky
well I could go Queen here if Knight
here he'd releases pressure on this pond
and then I'll play Queen c2 okay mm-hmm
maybe I don't I don't know about two
avoiding the knight exchange I could try
for that now you know what the bishops
gonna look to take out one of my Knights
so okay let's go in for this
my queen is one step away from getting
to see three I may need to okay how to
recapture actually should I give up on
this idea to put pressure on this pond
with a knight take with the bishop
instead I'm going to take with the
bishop
and maybe look for what next
hmm
be three I think I want my queen on b2
anticipating a capture here and
potentially some play against the veep
on I'm on the night
okay
I gotta save that pun mine I could
actually in a way be out of play
yeah my night might be a bit out of play
where's their night going
okay they're gonna jump into g3 I guess
yeah my knight is out of play yep he's
out of play let's go here I think I need
to kick that night soon it's not going
to be easy
well I my knight is out of flight so I
got to get them into play here maybe my
queen is the best piece on b6 or my rook
exerting pressure here my phone my mom
pon restricts those two they're on f2
but I have the cover with my queen the
knight moves there on c4 143 to 3
I saw that that is ammo let's go at this
rook you know because if there's ever
any beep on advance I want to have
immediate pressure with my rook on the a
file so I'm just looking for a knight
exchange
I think they should avoid the heavy
piece ending because of this stuff and
maybe I wind up upon eventually because
they're in a pin okay and they're going
straight in for this so this is my most
vulnerable pawn right now there's some
pressure on it but I could get my King
over here okay so this is happening
pressure on the a pawn I'm not going to
be easy
let's go g4
yeah this trip this rook can't move if
he doesn't if I take this guy
same story there Kings gonna come over
here I think I might want to clamp down
with g5 it feels a bit too early to do
that let's improve the King still
let's try for it neck next see if they
got King f6 is this good enough of a
shelter I don't want the King getting to
e5 opposite the if I get to this sixth
rank doing some good things okay I guess
we're going to take
and let me give a check first if he goes
here there's some mating that ideas big
decision for that king
he's living dangerous if he goes here
God defend that pond right back here
No okay so let's scoop him up I'm gonna
inconvenience their King I think this is
the right idea here to stop this they
didn't do that
that's a misstep so I'm winning the deep
on am i winning the game though
ideally I'm gonna get I'm gonna try at
least to get the rook right behind the
pond
and let's improve the king something
like this rook behind the pawn can I
just win this guy should I cut the king
out first mmm
let's get here straight away there's no
increment 36 seconds gotta get a move on
King up pawn up
I have a nice little shelter here for my
King tough to get out
you know I think I should be able to
manage this efore checking here mate
threats let's push on here this might go
after this guy I got that covered though
because of this double function defend
the pond and throw a strike at f7 so one
King and pawn ending I'm going to
revisit this square court grip
let's get rook here 25 seconds and then
I go here I want to set them up for some
pins f5g six stuff got a watch for a
pawn push and me losing my rook actually
that would be a threat if the King moved
so now we're gonna do this and then this
next or check let's start with the check
11 seconds I'm forgetting that this
isn't
there's no increment here
just improve my King as much as possible
seven seconds let's win this pawn
then come back over here and then push
my off pawn
one of them's gonna promote their down
on time who tough game
I went in the wrong direction without
question with this Knight b6 this idea
to recapture on c4 with upon I took away
of really good square for my knight by
doing that hmm now let's go into the
analysis its what the arrows out for a
moment
um okay let's see a Benoni I like this
system here where I mean there's a
couple approaches one is to put your
pawn on e4 the other one is at e3 this
is a more positional minded unless you
know a less tactical game Bishop on f4
pawn on e3
working more of a controlled game let's
say stop b5 drop the bishop back so
we're seeing some games with this here's
one game let's see how much further we
follow okay we were following it up to
this point a game between Ivan Sokolov
and this guy
like how I avoided that pronunciation
this guy I'm just curious how how this
game played out just want to get a feel
for how it was played out I played a
couple of these standard type moves and
there's a blitz game yeah okay now
things are sharpening up here on the
Kings side so both wings are really
being made use of how much further do I
want to take it wow it's already game
over
black resigned at that point
what's the reading on this hmm what's
the trick here just curious
clean back takes Knight takes brother Oh
killer and if you're taking with the
Queen then you're running into this this
this is too much okay yeah this is
opening up the diagonal for the Queen
there is no F pawn around okay well I
just want to get a feel for some of the
moves in one of the top games from this
position right here after Bishop h2
they're going for a dark square Bishop
exchange this interesting idea
we sometime
I wasn't able to really get at their
king you know he's a key defender
normally but the Queen does a pretty
good job of controlling the dark squares
I don't really I didn't really see a way
into let's say attack the black King in
this game are we still following a game
even up to this point so I guess one
game we should be - yeah so right around
here yeah I was really lacking a plan at
this stage when I played Queen d2 I
guess what I could try you know what
what I didn't see is that my knight is
defending this pawn so I could look to
restrict this Knight
one take on this position is that if I
could control the night I control maybe
the whole Queen side you know without
this night moving the bishop doesn't
move the rook doesn't move I guess if I
take away e5 by playing f4 which is
pretty weakening he would have to go
here but where's he going next mmm I
have to be careful hmm
these are long-term weaknesses you know
maybe he's ready to jump in if I could
be assured of getting in this move it's
a different story but am I going to get
that in I'm not so sure with all these
pieces here yeah it's a it's a thought
but one that is the timing is just not
there
different if I could get these guys in
and then be threatening a vibe and
similar to the game I just briefly
skimmed through with Ivan Sokolov you
know if I could get this pawn up if he's
ever capturing then this guy is what
he's past and is quite a dynamic asset I
would say
so Knight e5 let's see something else
right around here it's okay I guess
weights Queen to d2 what is the all
right where was it okay I'm just winning
in that that ending okay that's where
it's saying I'm winning as soon as I as
soon as the King goes to f8 I guess it's
still it's tollable if the King goes
here but he went to f8 and then it's
winning but yeah we're a long way off
from that position but this middle game
yeah what could I have done different
right around here instead of Queen to d2
what is it suggesting here rook c1 ah
okay with this as an idea
rook c1 you know it strikes me as a bit
unnatural to pull the roof off of this
file because he does have a a
responsibility of watching over the a5
pawn but my knight satisfies that job
quite nicely so I could look for this
and ninety five takes with b4 ideas or
even B for right away it's suggesting
okay this is an interesting idea you
know and also if you could just envision
these two pawns exchanged there's now
maybe a new way to strike at d6 you know
maybe getting my Queen here if these
guys are off but yeah a rook opposite
the Queen who's pretty short on squares
is she not you know there isn't there
isn't a whole lot of space here for
black so if I could add one more piece
into the mix let's get turn out quite
good so I'm taking note of this little
idea simply putting the rook opposite
the Queen it is a half-open file after
all with this b4 idea okay
instead of what I did in the game which
was Queen d2 okay so that's just a quick
point to take away doesn't like my queen
bee to idea
this is what the computer suggests well
I mean I'm having I have to take with
the pawn right now as otherwise I'm
dropping this guy but I shouldn't be
going with this Queeny - as a suggestion
I guess to strike at the knight in this
way and also defend upon now but on this
Bishop takes I have to take with the pun
I don't like this this feels very
uncomfortable yeah mine I just feel like
he's out of flight yeah cuz where are
his moves I mean these forward moves are
no good and these are illegal where's
where's he gonna go yeah I don't like
this idea I have to I have to keep this
square open for my knight so maybe this
on Bishop takes taking with the knight
is better you know it's tough I don't
know how well we could really trust
stockfish here with assessing this this
capture with the pawn or keeping a disc
we're open for a piece once we got into
a heavy piece ending though I was happy
I thought they would do well to avoid
the knight exchange and try to stir up
some trouble here like this defend the
pawn laterally and then maybe you know
some action over here clamp down on my
king side structure with h4 in this
ending here as as I was pointing out I
think right around this point that's why
I wanted to go with this rook
anticipating this I want to keep
pressure on the a pond and it should be
a draw I mean I'm just trying to squeeze
a little something out of this ending
improving my king I think this is the
best try as otherwise feels like the
king is getting too active and I didn't
want to give some targets to my
opponent's king but I have to give
something up in order to get something
in this ending so that's why I felt like
I needed to go with f4 and
this check first I thought if I went
here the g5 is maybe a move although I'd
be expecting on this they are suggesting
to take and then push but this is
something that could be undermined with
f5 it's tricky
I played g5 first still even ich until
they played King f8 and now it's gone
yeah they had to play King II 8 and
tough to make progress yeah I mean what
do I do here
the king has the he'll be around to
watch over these guys material is
balanced let's just say I stay on the
seventh rank
I believe this rook could just stay here
keeping my king
keeping my king cut off there's multiple
ways I'm sure could do this and then
always question my Kings position yeah I
don't I don't see enough in this
position for me to win I don't see a
great way to activate my King if I could
somehow manage to get my king I don't
know to the sixth rank it's a different
story because I could combine made
threats then with my king and rook but
how do I pull that off and let's see
that happening so I'm only winning at
this point because of a maybe who knows
maybe it was even a mouse leap at that
point but King f8 throws the game away I
win the pond and yeah it's just gone
from here no slips here's one little
thing I have to be watched watching out
for King f8 if let's say I push my pond
um I guess this is still strong for me
this is still winning you know but
there's this little trick you know you
don't want to have to calculate this
kind of stuff but apparently it's still
winning with King e6 and then a push and
then he's going through okay but yeah I
would just want to transfer my rook so
that way I could play against this guy
maybe pin him in some way okay well
interesting game sharp game out of this
benoni I've played both setups one with
on a pond on e4 another with the game is
III what is your preference feel free to
leave your feedback to this video in the
comment section below
are you more of an e4 base set up efore
based player or III as in the game which
you prefer this is more dynamic this is
more positional feel free to leave any
feedback in the comments section below
and as always I hope you got something
on this video that's all for now take
care bye